[Music]
what's you guys take on art
are you guys that's beautiful yeah is it
[ __ ] or you guys like it's real it's
trolling it's real it's a really good
way for a if you want to evade taxes
yeah yeah are you talking about like
modern art like
splatter it's a million dollars
whatever
it's one million dollars like that or
like actual like whoa that painting
looks like a photograph what does it
mean to you
art now what does art these days mean to
you bart quan anything that gets you to
emote oh really that takes some skill
though oh that's true it takes some
skill to get so a homeless guy [ __ ]
on the [ __ ] ground in front of your
house you're getting gross if someone
got a polaroid
and go
that's art right there okay all right
yeah and then you get the homeless guy
to kiss the back
okay sign his name have him put lipstick
on sword actually
and then whatever that polar auction is
for it gets donated to that homeless guy
oh cool so what do you guys think this
is
not art dude a korean spicy cucumber
that was dropped on a white piece of
paper it looks like a blood stain oh
that looks like a cucumber a pickle
that's a pickle from a mcdonald's
hamburger face
it is a pickle from a mcdonald's
hamburger you [ __ ] knew it man i know
my [ __ ] bro
guilty pleasures that he [ __ ] loves
mcdonald's i [ __ ] love fast food
don't [ __ ] with me my fast food right
when you said it i was like oh yeah that
does look like that so this was he's an
artist this was this was flung at a
ceiling
in an art gallery
so like an artist got the victor's
burger and wraps it takes the pickle
and it did it and it stuck yeah the
artist did it
and so he debuted this work that he
titled pickle
it is a single slice of pickle he
plucked from a mcdonald's cheeseburger
chucked it at the wall at the white
ceiling of the gallery space
it never fell from the spot oh [ __ ] and
he now
is charging sixty five hundred dollars
for this
piece of art but how are they gonna yeah
are they gonna saw it off
that's a good price i don't [ __ ] know
okay so
art like this um is
is
clever when you do it the first time but
i also think that once this guy gets
paid like 6 500 i think he should get
jacked for like 10 grand
when you say the first time do you count
the first time as the duct tape banana
and this is just him biting well i don't
know because dude chomp
wasn't due trump the first time he
literally takes a toilet in an art
museum he puts a toilet in there and
he's like i call it toilet and
everyone's like holy [ __ ]
that's that voice you're not a holy [ __ ]
every time steve does this you know it's
[ __ ] on and popping you know
like
there's this there's a category of what
is it called it's not like shock art or
like they call it shark
fart
it's like a vaughn guard art right it's
like yeah it's like trolling which again
from time to time i get it yeah but it's
like
come on it's a [ __ ] mcdonald's pickle
there is something cool about when
someone's hyping up a certain exhibit
and then when the time finally comes to
reveal it and it's just a [ __ ] pickle
that's pretty ballsy that's funny yeah i
think context and story yeah maybe can
make that like extremely powerful or
like let's say like this um the person
who did it was already an esteemed
artist and he was just like man [ __ ]
this scenario right that's what it is
it's like imagine if quentin tarantino
had a new movie out everybody's hyped to
see it and then the screening is just a
two second flash of a pickle and then
credits yeah everybody's gonna talk
about it do you think the only reason
why people are talking about this is
because it's so [ __ ] stupid and then
because everyone's talking about it it
just provides value to it it's kind of
like provocative it gets the people
going it's kind of like the the ten
thousand dollar burger the [ __ ] half
what is it like fifty thousand pizza
yeah gold flakes and whatever the [ __ ]
and nobody really wants to eat it very
much yeah it always tastes like [ __ ] my
favorite piece of art that i've bought
was i think 35 bucks
and it's leonardo and donatello but the
heads
is michael scott and dwight schrute
that's pretty cool
man of [ __ ] great taste i think that
was an iq test as well
it was like this big
where do you hang it up i'm gonna hang
it i didn't hang it up i'm all up my art
collection i'm compiling it and then i'm
gonna hang it up in the right places so
one day you're gonna hang up your art
collection it's gonna go it's gonna
happen like the next pop like that's
right
i saw this one dude on a [ __ ] tick
tock he
sculpted basically
he got like a head a skull right put
like a samurai like like helmet on and
then like he made like a a mold out of
it and then he [ __ ] like
you see the whole process of the statue
and then he paints it and it's like a
[ __ ] metal like skull with the
samurai head and it's like i was like
damn that [ __ ] is [ __ ] sick dude um i
think it was like a couple grand but
then i went on to a store and he has
like multiple themes of like skulls with
like warrior helmets like they had the
[ __ ] gladiator one and all that and i
was like now that is art
dude's [ __ ] on the ground and taking
a picture of that they should [ __ ]
eat that [ __ ] well what do you think
about this so there's another layer to
this right if you wanted to see this
piece of art
you would have to pay 6500 to go into
the exhibit to see it but now oh it's
6500 a c unfortunately though that's
[ __ ] nonsense unfortunately though
the exhibit is now closed good so if you
want to shell out
uh 6 329
for the work
you can find um you will not receive the
pickle from the exhibit but instead you
will be given instructions on how to
recreate the art in your own space shut
the [ __ ] oh my god who's paying for this
i am yeah me too i'm in i'm in for half
all right cool i think most of these
things are big [ __ ] jokes right and
they don't expect anybody to pay for it
no they expect people to pay for it
because of the publicity
this is on today.com bro if people are
going to pay for it i want to know who
bought it and why a [ __ ] loser well
in the same way that like an artist
might be like ah look at this dude i'm
gonna sell this for like 6 500. but
you're just [ __ ] wealthy ass tycoons
they're like haha dude i'm gonna blow
6500 on this piece of [ __ ] yeah well you
guys know about ether rocks right ether
rocks are like this entity that's right
earliest ones and they were selling for
like [ __ ]
oh god six figures i think at one point
it's crazy just just stupid [ __ ]
rocks on the blockchain yeah people were
hella buying them more like the rock
chain
now
well yeah so the um the most complex
part of the brine based work to digest
for some is the description of the
artworks medium while the label at the
louvre for the mona lisa says mask the
masterwork is painted with oil on poplar
wood and any number of works by edgar de
gas are simply drawn by
by dry pastel pickle includes quite a
bit more than just a pickle it says
regular bun wheat flour wheat sugar
canola oil wheat gluten glaze iodized
salt yeast improver
enzymes preservative beef patty has beef
cheese milk salts you get it i got it
it's mixed medium right there it looks
happy at the end of the day if it makes
it onto jk it deserves the pay like you
know you know what i mean if we talk
about it it that we just upped the value
of this we just gave it 8 000 more views
we spread awareness that's what i'm
saying
maybe 6 500 on a good day i still think
this guy should still get jacked
afterwards do you guys have a piece of
art that's like your favorite that you
guys have at home
oh boy
which nft you know what i'm saying uh
actually honestly i have this cool nfg
called a dystopia which is oh that's
right yeah dot ai
you can take any um every month they
allow you to generate using a computer
algorithm a brand new nft and it gets
sent to your blockchain address
so i took this monkey i [ __ ] love all
these office monkey um pictures have you
ever seen the office monkey pictures
where it's like they took they had like
a baboon in an office one day and they
took a bunch of pictures of them like at
a desk with glasses on and he's like
[ __ ] got a phone and [ __ ] he's got a
briefcase and like he's got money and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] always makes me laugh so
hard i can barely even breathe monkeys
doing human [ __ ] is the best the best i
got the chimpanzee with a banana holding
it at like a gun i love that [ __ ] so i
got it i took one of those pictures of
it right of this monkey's like smiling
like this it's like my discord um um
whatever you call it avatar
and i
sent it into the the algorithm and they
spit me back probably my favorite entity
in my collection now what is it i'll
also have the editor so you guys can see
it but it's sick it's uh i'll pull it up
is it a chimpanzee it's a chimpanzee but
it's like it's what they did with it
right i'll show you the before and i'll
show you the after and like this
computer like algorithm did generated
this and i just love it i think it's
sick it's my favorite
i um bought this one piece of art in
kauai
it's the most
eastern point
of a bookstore in the whole us because
you know kauai is all the way in the
[ __ ] eastern part of the u.s right so
in this bookstore family owned they also
have like local artists that come in and
[ __ ] curate their [ __ ] right
and then this one they [ __ ] drew a
lady they got up they got a book
and then they tore out the page and then
they they [ __ ] drew a like a like
what looks like a hawaiian lady with her
[ __ ] hairs just all sick and it's
like flowing in the wind and [ __ ] and
i'm like damn that's dope and then like
if you can you can kind of like make it
out and you can read you're like what
are they talking about it's like a novel
or some [ __ ] but i thought that was
really cool it's way cool mm-hmm i'm
looking for my [ __ ] mind
what about you guys yeah what kind of
what are you laughing at he just looks
so bored
[Laughter]
okay so here's the nft right so this is
this is what i sent them
to get altered into the
through the ai algorithm right so this
is the the original
which i [ __ ] laugh at this one oh you
got a bad boo yeah he's a bad bad
oh i thought you got to chimp at z no no
he's a baboon right and then uh so check
this out right
this is what it got turned into
what do you mean there's nothing to show
here [ __ ] you
okay there we go
this is where this is what i got turned
into
whoa oh that's pretty crazy crazy yeah
and that's an ai that day yeah i did it
yeah not no human being to die oh
it's like a snorkeling baboon that's
pretty [ __ ] cool it's kind of crazy
yeah so i really like i really like this
one yeah so we should like blow that up
into something i'm going to i'm gonna
have a man i'm gonna put behind me in my
corner for my crypto corner shift
[Music]
so
[Music]